has there ever been a situation where
you scored a big role but that you
stopped and you looked at it and you
said you know what like I'm just not the
right fit for this role or this project
and have done it away yeah hello
everyone welcome back for a brand new
episode of ladies night I wanted to like
really tee this one up but I just can't
because I'm sitting next to Linda
Hamilton right now for terminator dark
fade thank you so much for your time
today well and beyond thrilled about
this right now and this is all over I am
going to kill you I understand
I'll be back everything from back to the
beginning to terminator dark fate and
maybe some other really random things in
the mix oh okay I kind of wanted to go
way back to the very beginning for you
and I'm just curious is there a movie a
TV show or performance is there one
specific thing like that that made you
say like I gotta be an actor oh boy it's
getting deep already what was the movie
with Jane Fonda and Vanessa Julia I
liked I loved Julia some part of me just
was like I I want to do that a good call
right there yes I was also doing my
research and I was reading that early on
you had a professor that told you you
would never make a living as an actor
and I just feel like overcoming
something like that is very important
and maybe other people out there could
benefit from hearing you know what you
did how how did you take that when you
first heard it and then what did you do
to get past it
well I think he probably called me out
because I was a little snot in college
and I actually didn't have a lot to do
as a college theater department because
I could see how everyone is just fawning
over the professor to get the parts and
you know that is just so not me so I
went and did community theater while I
was in college so I sort of just was not
part of the college you know institution
and maybe that was why he was just like
mm-hmm
I can understand that yeah but so of
course I didn't believe him cuz I was a
little snot oh you didn't believe him
cuz look where you are now there is a
big difference between saying I want to
be an actor and then really believing
like it could be the real deal
so was there one specific project that
kind of switched that thought process
for you that made you say like it's like
I'm here I got this I have always made
the distinction and for me it was just
completely organic like I never said I
wanted to be an actress I said I am an
actress and maybe that's the difference
but for me it was just authentic to say
that
so you don't have to be working to be an
actress or you don't have to be
validated by some social structure or
construct to say or to be an actress so
that might be the difference between me
and the next person I feel like that's
so applicable in any field no matter
what your dream is if you just raise it
like that you say it enough and you
believe it that's I am and that's kind
of the key actually jumping off that
mentality
what is it cuz the audition process is
always something that's fascinated me I
just can't imagine going in and either
getting apart or not getting apart so
what did you do you know early on in
your career when you didn't get
something did it ever get you down or
were you able to move on and go to
something else they were I'm sure a few
times that it was disappointing but one
has to move on and really the
auditioning process is a totally
different skill set from acting so I've
known great actresses that just couldn't
do auditions and will never couldn't
make it because it's a different skill
set but I was always rather healthy and
knew that they didn't want me I probably
didn't want them do you know that it has
to you know it takes both ends to really
sort of meet yeah somewhere so it's just
like okay next so for anybody out there
that wants to know what the specific
skill sets are like let's say somebody
is a super talented actor that deserves
a part but they just can't get the
audition process right do you have any
kind of advice or you know a tip or a
trick to apply to that oh after enough
years I think my approach was simply you
can't let them take Linda Hamilton out
out of Linda Hamilton like when we go in
an audition we are not ourselves
particularly we ourselves when we walk
into that room though and so I just
plant I'm an air sign so it took me a
long time to just like plant myself and
go the terror or the silence or the
awkwardness that is in this room because
you don't know what they want and no
one's telling you they are not going
take Linda Hamilton out of me and so
that was just something that would just
bolster me in those moments of like
what's going on here
you know it's like Linda Hamilton is in
the room you know and then I do the best
work that I can given the information
that I have but I can't let them take
Linda Hamilton out of Linda Hamilton so
it sounds I'm gonna make an assumption
that you really care about kind of
gelling with the person that you're
working with the role that you've been
given has there ever been a situation
where you scored a big role but then you
stopped and you looked and you said you
know what like I'm just not the right
fit for this role or this project and
has done it away yeah maybe I don't know
any actress that has ever stepped away
you know I'm not the best person for
this part but yes I've gone in many
times and just maybe won something or
you know you get into your mid-career
and sometimes things are offered to you
which is just amazing and then you learn
over time that the things that are
offered to your generally things that
you don't want to do and that's why you
know you're gonna bolster the project as
opposed to it's going to bolster your
career so you're like and you start
reading offers with a little trepidation
or putting off reading them because
you're hoping it's good but I have
walked into work situations where it was
clear once I met the director and the
actors that I was working with that
nobody really cares that I'm ever really
wanted me there like I might be a studio
choice or a network choice but I'm not
the directors choice particularly you
know I mean I've been stymied a couple
of times and you know walked in and met
the team and they're all I Hey and I'm
like oh what's going on here because I'm
winning I'm charming but you know it
just sort of like you know occasionally
it's not a great fit in the directors
mind but he's clearly been bullied into
hiring me and that doesn't ever feel
good so to flip that around a little
what is the key to finding someone that
you
no you have that right working
relationship with has there been any
consistent factor among all the great
individuals you've worked with in the
directing positions really amazing and
acting very different because you don't
get to choose your actors
I mean rarely you know sometimes when
you're doing theater you can recommend
someone but you know with actors it's
just there's chemistry or there isn't
there's something or there isn't and we
expect that you know but we also expect
that and know that we have to correct it
and sell it on screen to make it look
like there's chemistry there you know
and with directors it's really just a
question of do they speak a language
that can change you on a dime you know
it's just can they be precise enough to
allow you to understand what they want I
mean I've had directors that are like
okay what I really need is more hey you
got me hmm and I'm like nope you're
gonna have to use words you know
everybody speaks their own language and
the the joy of what we do is we try to
find a common language so we can make
the same movie yeah film school and I
don't think I really fully grasped that
until they force you to do a directing
the actors class and every student had
to be directed by another yes oh this is
what it feels like and this one this is
why for many people out there right we
understand what we want but to make it
understood is a whole other thing so I
wanted to ask you a little bit about
your IMDB page because I've gotten into
the habit I love going through the
trivia and there they also have this
trademark section and there's only true
to trademarks there for you because I
don't read IMDB but I'm glad for you
about it oh please I asked a way I
okay decided that in Box Office Mojo
frequently portrays women who endured
despite great hardship or tragic tragedy
and then there's also muscular and toned
arms I think they are both accurate and
they're both winning qualities but I'm
curious if you could add a trademark
about yourself to that list that's
really meaningful to you what would it
be
mmm think of my feet
I think that's even overstating my
skills
well my arms aren't the same mm-hmm
really good sport okay I think you also
said it earlier it's like you can never
take the win to Hamilton out of Linda
Hamilton and anyone in this industry who
could stand their ground like that
should be here I hope so
because I've seen great actresses
standing outside of a room getting ready
to audition for a pilot and they're
standing against the wall going I can't
breathe I mean that means someone has
taken you out of yourself do you know
what I mean they want it so badly you
have left yourself because it's amazing
you can see great actresses that are it
because an audition process and a screen
test for a pilot it just gets meaner and
meaner with every passing year you know
being a movie star means nothing
whatever now I'm so old nobody knows who
I am but it's so interesting to watch
other people that you think are like the
total it girl right now and they're just
like it's hard it's hard doing what we
do yeah and winning the part oh I really
can't even begin to wrap my mind around
it I'm also curious to see what you
think about how just the like the
typical role you were cast in and being
typecast in in that kind of strong lead
female hero how that's changed from back
in your Terminator and t2 days to you
know what we see nowadays especially
having worked with Mackenzie Davis who
you already know I think the world of so
you know that kind of character type how
have you seen that change from then to
now well I never would have seen myself
as the strong action-adventure star
until you are asked to do it once or
twice and you perform well like never
and the first Terminator I wasn't really
a badass I mean there's a moment
badassery when I'm on your feet soldier
and you know so it had to grow from
there second time I knew where I had to
go because it's been seven years and the
character knows what's coming and she's
the only /
on earth that knows what's coming so
she's got to be sick and crazy and she's
you know John the Baptist a voice in the
wilderness trying to warn people and so
in that way I knew I had to be a badass
a soldier and I said to Jim as he was
right before he wrote it I said you got
to make her crazy because anyone that's
living with that all by herself is gonna
be [ __ ] crazy so you know that's all
character work in acting work I just you
know I never really ever saw myself as
the iconic action hero other people
might assign it to me yeah then Myka oh
my god your arms or oh my god I went to
the gym after that or oh my god but you
know it's just a job and in terms of
role model and iconic could iconic it
city iconic miss it was only it was only
after I finished this one that I really
felt like holy [ __ ] I am a badass I have
so many follow-up questions I'm gonna
ask one and I guarantee you I forget the
second two so going back to what you're
saying at the very beginning never
looking at yourself as the action hero
like that when you first started out did
you have kind of a picture of where you
would go in your career in your mind
Shakespearean actress stage because I
studied at Strasbourg in New York and
we're all stubs and you know they you're
gonna be ruined if you go to LA because
you just get lost and but I loved stage
and I think that would have been quite
enough for me but I was also young and
kind of shy which might be a little hard
to imagine because I really it took me
years to outgrow it but I had agents who
said you're not gonna make it on stage
you're too quiet you're too shy you
belong on screen and so they made me
come to LA after training in New York
they're like we think you belong on
screen and so they brought out a group
of actresses to sort of start as their
stable of young actors
you know our news at the time and and
now I could own the stage I mean it's
kind of hard to believe that that was
and I remember being in their office and
being really shy you know Pam Reed do
you know who she is Pamela Reed would
come in when we were contemporaries we
were both new at the agency and she
could just walk in there and entertain
them and own the room and make them
laugh and I just be sitting there in
like out in the hallway you know I mean
I just didn't know how to command a room
now I can you definitely dead you can
see it in all your work and you can feel
it here even though you said in five
minutes I was in there it's not true I
am let's try to remember all these
follow-up questions I had actually
another one came to mind as you were
explaining it Strasburg method acting
yes so I feel like there are so many
different assumptions of what method
acting is yeah I think it's different
from actor to actor so what does it mean
to you and do you still use those
techniques today um the last class that
I ever had at Strasburg and I was there
mostly on for about four years and the
last thing that my best teacher said to
me was that was a really good scene I
get the feeling you're not using much
method and you're acting I took a lot
from it I mean I do believe that it
really you know I arrived as a very
small town girl and it kind of just
shredded everything that were the bad
habits and the things that I thought I
knew and just sort of built rebuilt me
and it is an amazing tool for a lot of
people it's not that I'm a disbeliever
and I think there's part of me that just
sort of automatically uses some of the
method and the substitutions and things
but for me it was a little complex you
know bring this exercise and bring this
exercise in then work on your animal
then and it's amazingly effective for
some people for me it was a little - I'm
I'm already in my head enough so I just
ultimately was like I think I'm just
gonna jump in and believe you know work
on your animal oh that's one of the
exercises that's one of the more complex
animals that they I mean exercises that
they do wait what is that work study and
not imitate because it's not imitation
you just I mean I worked on gorilla I
went studied and studied and it's the
feeling the movement that I mean maybe
whenever you need to be a beast or you
know I mean I can't really instruct you
on how one would use it but you get
there and really really really work on
all the parts the physicality of the you
know of the gorilla or whatever animal
you choose I love hearing about that
kind of yeah so you would choose a
different animal for instance for a
different part if that's what but along
with that you're working on room and
smell and all these other things that
you bring in and I mean it's it's very
complex but I'm not that complex it
turns out I'm intuitive and I'm pretty
brave so I think maybe that made up for
it I think those are two excellent
qualities to have you also mentioned
earlier in that other question that you
didn't really believe you were an action
hero until was it this movie was a dark
fate no I never ever saw myself as an
action hero but I never felt like I was
a real badass until this okay why would
this one you know be people say you're
such a badass and I'm like yeah yeah
yeah I mean you might as well buy into
that as as any stuff that people try to
force feed you you know it's like after
Judgment Day these everybody thought it
was not just a badass but like I was so
competent that I would be in a bar and
on location somewhere in Virginia
shooting pool and I would hear someone
whisper I can't be Sarah Connor she'd
shoot pool a lot better than that like
you know people buying into this idea of
I am just a superior woman so you're
like yeah yeah
so you know and I don't give myself
titles or like I don't need to say I'm a
badass I Know Who I am you know I'm a
hard worker and that's pretty good
that's a subsection of badass perhaps
but this one was just so hard physically
it was just it was three times at least
what the last film was just by the very
nature of where films have gone and how
big things have gotten so that the
action was three times the amount the
you know the physicality the emotional
demands the mental demands it was huge
and hard
[Music]
[Music]
we'd be you know in the tank and the
water seems and we fight in the water we
fight in the air we fight on land you
know I read the script and I'm like huh
I mean there were sequences that only
III don't get what I'm reading I mean
that this is the first time where I'm
like what and what turbine and like
there were so many moments that I
couldn't link together because it was
just so huge and that's the way it was
every day
is there any specific moment shooting
this film that you said I can't believe
how stunt work is done today on dark
fate compared to t2 well to the better
and for the better and for the worse
because well there were more stunt women
I really got a little crazy trying to
micromanage because I mean to every
detail like she can't be the back of me
cuz her wig needs cutting like I'm not
gonna give one moment away that doesn't
seem real so like okay you have to be in
a wire here and go down this hill and we
could have debbie do it cuz it's just
the back of you and I'm like nope Debbie
needs her hair cut like you know I'm
like I'll do it and I didn't do it that
well but you know what I mean I just you
don't want that one second that's gonna
break the audience concentration or then
there would be the stunt girl from
Hungary that they'd hired and that's a
whole different school old school of
stunts where you know and the girl is
doing good work but it's real old school
so she's in a car accident she's
flinging herself around cuz selling it
and I'm like no no Sarah Connor does not
thrash like yes you sell it but you
don't look like you're an out-of-control
rag doll because this is Sarah Connor
like you know it's so hard to not get in
there and it's not so much that I'm a
control freak but more like I just I Oh
Sarah Connor
the dignity I don't want to disappoint
her you know so this was the one film
that I've done where I was kind of that
person I was protective of every moment
and I couldn't be there because it's a
larger film and they're off in Spain
doing little stuff and you know it just
it was it was really hard what is it
like jumping back into the character
here do you automatically just fall back
into step with her or do you have to go
back and I don't revisit time potater in
t2 because they're also such distinct
chapters of her life I haven't looked
back or thought about her even seen the
movies for so long
essentially I think though some partly
Girt lingers but it's not just directly
after it's 27 years later so I might
think I have an understanding of Sarah
Connor but Sarah Connor 27 years later
what is her story where has she been and
how has that changed her so I had a lot
of work to do to fill it in just for my
own process and I worked really hard to
fill that in and so that whether you
hear the story of where I've been my
character has been it doesn't matter
because you'll see it you'll see how
it's taken its toll on her and and I
went to my places of greatest deepest
sorrow and disappointment because that's
where Sarah Connor lives and it was a
very long and hard and lonely place to
be and I don't mean that I live there I
mean I don't mistake my life for Sarah's
life but there was so much to get done
and it went on for so long and she is a
woman without a friend and after a while
that does start to sort of catch itself
on to you so I can under I can
understand that kind of mentality
especially when you've you've not only
lived with
in terms of playing her but I can't even
imagine how many people over there come
up to you and say like Sarah Connor made
a big difference in my life cuz we
didn't have many characters like her
then true and I think too that when you
go somewhere with a psyche and I've
worked long enough to learn to not let
harm come to myself I've watched it with
other actresses where they don't know to
protect themselves from where they're
going and and it's hard to explain I've
seen women go hysterically blind during
scene because what they're doing is
costing them so much and they're not
able to reel it in or really call it a
craft so it's not a craft if you can't
reel it back if you can't reel it out
and reel it in but when you're playing a
character like Sarah who is inflamed in
full aimed with fury and rage and
vengeance and anger and and purpose and
lost purpose I don't think the psyche
really knows the difference if you're
giving yourself inflammation you know
and well what is the root of all illness
is inflammation inflammation changes
ourselves inflammation is what makes us
ill and I think that not that I was on
the verge of anything but you know I
mean I really have to sort of think you
know my body still kind of inflamed
bursitis and tonight is the itis --is
it's like because I spent a year and a
half or really a year getting ready yeah
at least a year and a half being
inflamed and that is not my character
Linda Hamilton's character i i'm very
chill but when I was enflamed for so
long and I think it does it kind of cost
you something so when you go home from a
hard day of shooting or maybe from the
entire production what do you do to kind
of resent to yourself what's like your
go-to things not home
home I'm on the couch eating pie like
any real person cherry pie
right but definitely takes a public
during the during the filming I
basically because you work hard
physically all day long and I trained
for a year so I would come home and lie
down because my body needed the rest
because at my age truly rest is as
important as building you cannot build
unless you rest and so you know things
have slipped backwards a little bit you
know different information to get an
approximation of the result so I dressed
my body and read a book I read 40 books
on this dome oh my god because I got to
rest my body and take my mind elsewhere
so I became this completely compulsive
reader never at work cuz that's a
distraction but I would just get home
and if I had two days off it was pretty
much two days in bed reading so we like
to end these interviews with a couple
rapid-fire questions and that boy you
want to ask because I didn't read that
you're a voracious reader even beyond
this experience so what is the last book
you read ah
Icelandic noir called I see you I saw
you I know you yeah you'll have to look
that one up well but I I've sort of been
trying to read Icelandic nor anything
from Iceland I'll take it a heart yeah I
love I love them oh great yeah I'm going
to soon what's the last book you
recommend it for somebody else I guess
that just gentleman in Moscow is great
and which is a lovely lovely book and
probably my favorite I love Joe
Abercrombie because I read started to
read sci-fi adventure sci-fi fantasy
hadn't read it for 35 years and they
used to really read it and then you know
you leave it behind and oh yeah I'll
read the Man Booker list and the short
list in the long list and the Pulitzers
and then I'll mix in classics and it's
not that they don't read junk but you
know I read you know pretty pretty good
junk but the three-body problem
it was an Obama pick it's a Chinese
author so I'm not even going to try to
say his name but it's a trilogy and it
is just the most it's kind of a rough
start you know cultural revolution in
China but it really doesn't stay there
and it becomes this just amazing journey
tedious beyond words at times so complex
so quantum physics and your mind just
has to expand to understand it but
probably one of the best payoffs I ever
read for all the work that I put into it
yeah I need to put that on my list
three-body problem stick with it because
everybody's like I and I'm like I know
but so satisfying and really
multicultural right because you're just
learning that the Chinese do not think
the way Westerners think so even
including that you know it just makes it
really interesting do you have any pets
I do but not enough oh I - a small small
dog and a large dog what are their names
noodle and Turk that must be the best
thing to go home today I have a little
eyebrow a little Turk with me because we
were he's the big Anatolian Shepherd and
he had a momentary lapse on Wednesday we
were very controlled roughhousing I'm
very very controlled with him because
he's a powerful animal and he kind of
had a lapse and as I sat down he knocked
me back into a table and I have 10
staples in my head and whiplash so I've
got he's with me I have 10 staples in my
head it was such a shock
I'm sorry that happened but it's
something who like holds their pets like
at the highest level of my life I would
probably be in the same division that
was my dog's Thank You Turk just makes
this world tour that much more
interesting Halloween is right around
the corner ya have a costume plans not
gonna be home where we're traveling the
world
okay not a bad way to celebrate oh and
my costume is usually anymore it's more
like a mask for example keep it simple I
mean I used to go all out but you know
traveling during Halloween doesn't close
the door to candy so what is the
Halloween candy of choice Reese's peanut
butter cups forever right answer why is
this not everybody's answer I just know
because they're very wrong they are
wrong I just it will always satisfy me
yes I think I should get an endorsement
fee for just have you said that this is
a great transition because not only a
Reese's peanut butter cups very
satisfying but you know what always
later don't fade seriously go see it
Linda thank you so much you're welcome
all the best with the rest of the
promotion we do not miss terminate our
dark faith in theaters thank you so much
for watching this edition of colliders
ladies night like and share in this
video and
[Applause]
[Music]